[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIR TITIEVSKY: Hello.
It's 1:55.
As we all know, this is the
time when your circadian rhythms
push your body into
the most alert state,
ready to learn about Kafka.
So if you're here to learn
about Apache Kafka and Confluent
Cloud, the managed
Kafka service on GCP,
you're in the right place.
If you are here to learn
about Stream Analytics
and ingestion and
delivery of events
streams to real-time
applications,
you're also in the right place.
If you are not here for
any of these things,
you're also in the right place
because surely these topics
will become important for your
organization sooner than later.
My name is Kir.
I'm a product manager in
Google Cloud Platform,
and I work on stream
ingestion and delivery.
This means that I
spend my day working
with users of Google Cloud
Pub/Sub, our native ingestion
and delivery service and users
of Kafka, the open source event
ingestion and delivery system.
And today, I'm
finally able to extend
a proper welcome to
the Kafka users to GCP
now that we have a managed
service to talk about.
Now, this has been
a log time coming.
I try.
Thank you for those snickers.
See, now I don't have to ask you
to raise your hands if you're
on to Kafka production or not.
And for everyone
else, no worries.
I'll catch you up in a second.
And apologies for the bad joke.
So here is how we'll do this.
I will spend a few
minutes setting the stage.
I will talk about what we
mean by stream ingestion
and delivery, what companies
do with stream ingestion
and delivery systems--
we'll talk about
application patterns--
and I will answer
the question of,
when does it make sense
to use Kafka in GCP,
even though we have
a native service.
And then I will do my
real job and get out
of the way of the engineers.
And have Boerge
Svingen come on stage.
Boerge is the Director of
Engineering at the New York
Times, who has put
a Kafka cluster
on the way of every single
piece of published content
in this large media company.
He'll tell us why, what
that did for his company,
and the cost of running
Kafka in that critical role.
And once we've
gotten through that,
Gwen Shapira, the
senior architect
from Confluent and a
longtime Kafka advocate,
will come and share
Confluent's vision
for what happens when Kafka and
the entire ecosystem of Kafka
tools are easily accessible
within an organization.
And she will give
you the demo as well.
So let's get into it.
Streams of events everywhere--
we're getting increasingly good
at capturing interactions
with devices, digitizing them.
So this is no secret.
And as engineers, we're
increasingly often challenged
with turning these streams of
events into useful features--
useful, interesting,
entertaining things
for our users.
So, for example, in
gaming and media,
we're using in-session
user activity
to adjust gameplay
as the users play.
We're adjusting content
based on browsing history.
And we're certainly
adjusting the advertisements
as they show up.
Now, in e-commerce--
well, first of all,
if you're in e-commerce,
you're already also
are in the e-commerce
and media business--
but you're also building
recommendation systems, right?
And so, the recommendations
that you show me on page two
had better know what I just
did on page one 15 seconds ago.
In finance, this has, of course,
been a longstanding problem
where, let's say, the risk group
needs to aggregate events that
are trades in various
departments of a bank
as well as all the
market activity that's
happening outside.
So what's new is
the sheer scale.
Now, it used to be--
so people say,
maybe 20 years ago,
you could have a very
successful large business with
a 1,000-person call center
generating 100 events per
second.
Any messaging middleware
kept up with that,
and things were great.
Zoom to now, and I'm
routinely speaking
to customers of GCP
ingesting thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
millions of events a second
and doing something useful
with them in real time.
So what we need is not
just messaging middleware
but a high-throughput
ingestion and delivery system
for streams of events to
make sense of all this.
And, of course,
Kafka has sort of
become the de facto standard
of this kind of system
in the open-source community.
So I wanted to take
a couple of minutes
to just walk you
through some of the kind
of prototypical
patterns that I see
when I talk to users of Kafka
in Cloud Pub/Sub on an example
of a sort of a hypothetical
e-commerce business that
got its hands on a
high-throughput ingestion
and delivery system
for streams of events.
So the journey usually
starts with collecting
user interaction
events for analysis.
If you're going to create
a useful experience
for your customers, you need
to have your analysts and data
scientists go to the
warehouse and actually
figure out what's working.
And so the way we
build this is, I'm
shopping for shorts
and flip-flops,
so I'm viewing the shorts
page on my mobile device.
I tap on the shorts.
That generates a request
to stateless front-end.
That front-end is
stateless because it's
able to take advantage of a
high-throughput event ingestion
API to persist the event.
It just publishes
it right through.
It no longer has to worry
about writing it to disk.
It no longer has to
worry about writing it
to the database and
returns to the user.
On the other side, now we use
the delivery side of the API
to start building
processing pipelines.
So we'll start with the
Dataflow pipeline that
just grabs the events,
parses them, turns them
into structured data, puts them
in the warehouse-- so BigQuery.
Of course, soon enough, you
realize that you don't actually
need all the data.
You need some
aggregates or filtering.
So you just keep
adding these pipelines
as you understand what you need.
The beautiful thing is, your
front-ends are stateless.
You can add your back-ends
whenever you wish,
because, in the middle,
there's this thing that
is able to scale
with the throughput
and decouple the two systems.
So once you've done this,
your data scientists
make their first discovery.
And you're ready to create
your first feedback loop.
They discover that users tend to
buy things they've seen before.
And so what we want to build
is a simple feature where,
when I'm browsing
for shorts, I want
to see the history
of all the shorts
that I've seen before, right--
just a strip of my user history.
So we will build that a
recently viewed service.
Every time a request comes
in for a product page,
the front-ends reach into the
service with a user profile
and get back a list of
products I've browsed.
Perfect.
Very simple.
The question is, how do
we populate user history?
And that's simple as well--
just another Dataflow pipeline.
A browsing event comes
in-- a page view.
You grab the user ID, product
ID, stuff it into a big table.
Now you have a profile.
So this is working.
Your revenue is going up.
You're happy.
Your boss is happy.
You're ready to take the next
step, which will illustrate
another kind of common pattern,
which is handling events that
are just changes in a database.
We're doing change data capture.
And so, the goal now
is to capture changes
in a database of
an existing service
and materialize them
in something else.
So what we want to do now
is build an experience
where, when I'm
browsing for shorts,
I get a recommendation
for flip-flops,
because they're relevant--
not my browsing history.
So we build a
you-might-like-this service
that has a product graph.
You give it a product ID, it
gives you other product IDs.
We don't get this from the
customers' activity stream,
but we might have an
inventory management
service or some
other similar system
that your buyers use to sort
of select onboard products
to your e-commerce store.
And they're writing content.
They may be saying, this
comes in such-and-such color.
It's such-and-such brand.
This is starting to
look like useful data
that you can use to
build a product graph.
Accept that the database is
provisioned for your buyers.
These are the 10 people who are
responsible for what products
are sold, not the million
end-users you have.
So to deal with that problem,
we capture the change stream
from the product database,
turn it into events.
And from there, we
can build any number
of materialized views of that,
such as the product graph.
So these are the
common patterns.
Now out of habit,
I've been showing you
GCP hexagons, Cloud Pub/Sub,
my first product at Google.
So forgive me, but, of
course, in reality, Kafka
does all of these things
and, increasingly, not
just ingestion and delivery,
but also stream processing
with K streams and KSQL.
So the question is, why would
you want to use Kafka and GCP,
and would you?
Well, it turns out that
the answer to this question
is, there are at least
three reasons why you would.
And there are many others.
But it turns out to be
often the right choice.
So reason number one
is easy migration.
You're rarely migrating
to Cloud because you're
unhappy with your Kafka Cluster.
You're probably
migrating because you
want to change your
warehouse, or maybe you
want to take advantage of
Google Kubernetes engine
to run your
application front-ends.
Kafka will migrate
happily and live in Cloud.
So no reason to change what
doesn't need to be changed.
Second is, if you take a step
back, when you start migrating,
you're probably building
a hybrid environment.
Maybe that's part of your
sort of long-term migration
strategy.
Maybe that's the end-state
where you want to land.
And so, in this case, you want
your data exchange and access
layer to be something that
works both On-premises
and across public clouds.
So a native service,
like Cloud Pub/Sub,
is not the natural
solution in this case.
And as you will see, Kafka and
Confluent Cloud, in particular,
are very good at this problem.
And then finally, if you're
doing event sourcing,
this Kafka is absolutely
the right starting place.
Event sourcing takes advantage
of Kafka's particular way
of doing event ingestion
and delivery, which
is it's a complete log.
It allows you to
store events as they
come in in an append-only
log and then serve them out
in order.
When you have a
complete log that you
can read with high throughput
many, many times over,
you can use it to store
the set of changes
to a state or database and
then materialize that database
as many times as you
want without putting
a load on your source
database, as you
might do if you, for
example, were experimenting
with something that takes a lot
of different materializations
like an Elasticsearch cluster.
So event sourcing, hybrid
systems, and quick migrations
are three very good reasons
to start with Kafka on GCP.
Of course, as you succeed,
now you have a problem.
You have to run Kafka well.
Running Kafka well turns out to
be hard as really any system.
But I'm a product
manager, remember.
I don't get to run
anything in production.
They don't let me.
What I do get to do is I do
get to meet the people who do.
So I'd like to invite
Boerge to tell you
of his experience running
Kafka at the New York Times.
[APPLAUSE]
BOERGE SVINGEN: So thank you.
So what we're using
Kafka for at the Times
is making published content
available to our readers.
And this is what
that looks like.
So we have a blog post out that
describes how that actually
works.
I'm not going to go
into detail on that now,
only to say that this is an
example of advanced sourcing
or, specifically, a
log-based architecture.
So the core principle in
this is that we maintain
a log of every asset published
by The New York Times
since the beginning of it
in '51 and up until events
being published in real
time and now, I hope,
since we're all here this week.
There are two main principles
for running such a log.
We need two main requirements.
We need ordered playback,
because the published
events we are writing to the
log have causal relationships
between them.
So the ordering matters.
And the other thing is that
we need infinite retention.
We want this to be
available forever.
And only Kafka fulfills
both of those requirements.
Now, because Kafka is
such a critical piece
of our infrastructure, the
news doesn't get it out here
if our Kafka cluster is down.
And that's a very big
deal at the Times.
So because of that, we put
a lot of work and effort
into keeping this Kafka
cluster available and reliable.
So we have a dedicated team
of engineers running it.
And more concretely,
we're running this on GCE.
We might have chosen GKE
if we had started over now.
We have an Ansible script
that handles all our Kafka
deployments and rolling
updates and all of that.
We have set up multi-region
replication using MirrorMaker,
so everything published
to one Kafka cluster
becomes available everywhere.
Latency is very important
to us since this is news.
So we also have
implemented our own log
offset monitor that lets us know
if one of these log consumers
fall behind.
And we're also taking full
advantage of Kafka's ACLs,
specifically to limit
rights, because anything
being written to
this Kafka cluster
goes directly onto the site.
So we have to keep
very tight control
on who gets to write to it.
In addition to
all of this, we're
also very conservative in
how we use the cluster.
So, for instance, we don't
allow other teams at the Times
to use this Kafka cluster
for their own things.
And as a consequence
of that, using things
like Kafka Streams,
KSQL, and Kafka Connect
is a lot harder than
we would want it to be.
And in spite of all
of this, things still
sometimes go wrong.
So Kafka is highly
available in the sense
that, if a broker goes
down, things are still fine.
But when all the brokers are
logging excessively and run out
of disk at the same time,
that doesn't really help.
It also didn't help us when
we configured mutual SSL
authentication and all our old
communication between our Kafka
brokers stopped very
suddenly, which also brought
the entire cluster down.
Maybe the most frightening
case we've seen
was when one of our consumers
had its offset reset
and immediately started creating
a version of the New York Times
home page with old
news, which is really
not something we want.
Luckily, we managed to stop that
before it got to the reader.
But we do remember that day.
And basically, as a technology
strategy at the Times,
we want to run managed
services whenever we can.
We want to be good at news.
We don't want to be good
at running infrastructure.
And the reason we run
our own Kafka at all
and put in all the time and
resources and attention to that
is because, when we started
this project two years ago,
there was no managed
Kafka on GCP,
which I had long
discussions with Kir about.
Gwen?
GWEN SHAPIRA: So some people
want to be good at news and not
at running Kafka.
We, on the other
hand, at Confluent
are kind of crappy at news.
On the other hand, we're very,
very good at running Kaffa.
We've been running Kafka
in production our team
since the first lines
of code for Kafka
were ever written at LinkedIn.
About a year and change ago,
we announced Confluent Cloud
as a way to let us manage your
Kafka in the public cloud.
Now in order to really see the
value of what we're doing here,
I want to take you
a few years back--
back to the days where Kafka
was first invented at LinkedIn.
10 years ago, we started
seeing the microservices trend.
And the more microservices
we had, the more databases
each microservice had, the
more lines of communication
going back and forth between
microservices and database,
our entire infrastructure
became very complex, very
hard to manage.
Now this talk is not
about simplifying
the complexity of IT,
even though that's
a good topic of discussion.
It's about how Kafka can
help here and really simplify
your architecture.
So when you run
Apache Kafka, you
can now have connections between
the different applications.
In Kafka, every event
that is published to Kafka
is available to everything.
And this obviously
greatly simplifies.
You build a centralized
architecture
that allows you to
deploy new services
and give them access very
easily to all the data
that your organization has
at scale in a very reliable
distributed system.
Now, of course, the messy
infrastructure-- once
we started doing cloud
migrations and hybrid cloud,
it did not get any better.
In fact, it got a lot worse.
We took the mess that we
had in one data center,
and now we have a mess
in five data centers
and in this cloud provider and
in the other cloud provider.
And now that it's
going on public cloud,
it has real costs, and it
has a real security risk.
So the mess just got
a lot more expensive.
So think about the
same architectures
that simplified our
microservices deployment
OnPrem now applied for
both cloud migration
and in the cloud.
It really allows you to have
one channel of communication
to secure.
Each event is replicated
once, which drives down costs,
and you have this nice, much
easier to manage and monitor
architecture out there.
But that's not it.
Because you have all the data
available in Kafka 4 streams,
you can start experimenting
with everything
the clouds have to offer.
You want to try Dataflow.
You want to try TensorFlow.
You want to try BigQuery.
Even if you never did it before,
you're totally [INAUDIBLE]
very easy to just
stream events from Kafka
to BigQuery and
run an experiment.
So you really have a lot
more possibility out there.
And this is really divisions
that inspired Apache Kafka.
Connect everything to
everything from OnPrem
to the Cloud, microservices
and databases,
and make all the data available
to the entire organization--
kind of breaking down
all those silos vision.
But when building
a platform, it's
not just about the
platform itself.
That's a lesson that we
all learned from eBay.
You build a platform
to sell stuff,
but the point is the
stuff you actually sell.
The power of this
centralized platform
is from the things that
connect to the platform that
bring in the data and create
value to the business.
And the value is really
in the microservices
and the ecosystem.
So Confluent includes
a lot of components
that make it very easy
to create those very
lively ecosystems that
make data available
for your organization.
One of the coolest ones
is Schema Registry,
which allows you to make changes
to the schema of the events,
to the data that you are
transmitting, independently
between the producer of
the data and the consumer.
So the producer wants
to make some changes,
and you can do it
in very safe ways.
Agile is all about making
change and evolution safe.
Another cool tool is KSQL.
I think Boerge mentioned it.
It allows you to create
stream processing applications
using a very familiar
SQL-like language.
We also have clients in
pretty much every language.
You're seeing like eight here.
There's like 50 of
them that you can use.
If you like PHP, here
go Kafka PHP clients.
That's kind of the
power of open-source
is that, once you
have an open protocol,
everyone can create clients.
You're not depending on
anyone to do it for you.
Now, we mentioned databases,
and integrating microservices
and databases is
really what allows
you to run your entire
organization off
of one stream of events.
Kafka has the Kafka
Connect infrastructure.
And Kafka Connect allows
you to plug in connectors.
And we have 100-plus
connectors allowing
you to get data from different
databases into in Kafka,
from Kafka to other databases,
from Kafka to another Kafka.
If you want data from Vertica
to show up in Big Query--
people actually do it-- you
have a Vertica connector getting
data one way, BigQuery
connector the other way,
and you are good to go.
This is incredibly
powerful, especially
since it requires almost no
coding, and we run it for you.
So that's the
whole thing, right?
You want to use it.
You want to get at your data.
You want to build
your microservices.
You don't want to
actually run any of it.
And the reason you don't
want to run any of it
is that Kafka is a
distributed system.
And running distributed systems
is difficult. We should know.
Writing distributed systems
was difficult enough
in the first place.
It's kind of tricky.
But as we all know, debugging
is twice as hard as coding.
You're not allowed to be as
smart as humanly possible while
coding, because you need to be
twice as smart while debugging
something.
Raise conditions and
scheduler timing--
all this has been a thorn in
our side for a very long time.
Now operations is all
the fun of debugging
with time pressure,
customers yelling
at you, money ticking away.
What can be more fun?
So I want to just show you three
reasons that it's a good idea
to let someone else
run Kafka for you.
The first is that
random stuff happens.
And random stuff is usually
not that good stuff.
There are the failures
that we expect to see.
We kind of know that this will
fail, and machines may fail,
and the network
will have issues.
Those we plan for.
People who forget to renew
their SSL certificates,
not so much planned for.
But the thing is that,
when you have a strong team
and you build a strong system
that is capable of overcoming
failures, we have
the experience,
and you have the tools, and you
have the monitoring in place,
you can build very
resilient systems.
The trick is that this requires
experience and expertise.
You can build it in-house.
And most people do.
Boerge has an amazing
team that managed to build
something very resilient.
But, as you said, it may not
be your business to do that.
Even when nothing
absolutely fails,
you still have to make
changes to the system.
You can't just say,
"It works today.
Let's not touch it ever again."
Because even though there
is a risk of change--
every upgrade has a risk of new
bugs and things going wrong--
there's also a risk of
not changing, right?
We know that, if you
don't evolve and adapt,
you'll be left behind.
New features
actually have values.
They allow you to
implement things faster.
Some people are kind of sad
that they cannot use Kafka,
because they know that it
will allow them to move faster
and deliver value faster.
Why not offload
the risk to someone
who is being paid to take
this risk and go on your way?
You'll get the benefits.
And this is really the key--
you focus on your ideas,
we focus on running Kafka,
and everything will be amazing.
So I want to jump into a
demo, a kind of semi-live demo
where I show you how I actually
build one of the architectures
that Kir mentioned, streaming
data and joining it and doing
some processing to
it using Confluent
Cloud on multiple clouds.
So it will be a
hybrid cloud demo.
OK, so you can see here--
I have two clusters
in Confluent Cloud.
This is the Confluent Cloud UI.
You can see I have AWS and GCP.
I'm going to move
data between them.
You can see how big
my clusters are--
huge, right?
OK, those are demo clusters.
I want to create a new cluster.
I can choose a
name, and then I can
choose how large or small
the cluster is going to be,
which cloud it's going to be on.
And you can see that,
as I change my cluster
configuration, the pricing on
the right kind of automatically
adjusts to reflect
my new cluster.
If you pay a lot
of attention, you
can see that GCP is slightly
cheaper than the competitors.
Once I'm happy with
the configuration,
you can see that, if
I want more storage,
it's going to be slightly more
expensive than cases where
I want less storage.
I find the configuration.
I'm happy with the price.
I'm happy with my set-up.
I go in.
In this case, I'm canceling.
And let's see how you manage
those clusters that I now got.
So you can see here--
this is the list of topics
that I already have
in my GCP cluster.
And then, if I go to AWS, you
can see the list of topics
that I have in AWS cluster.
And suppose that I want to
see what is in the topic.
I can look at the schema.
I mentioned the Schema Registry.
And that allows me
to keep compatible.
You can see that, in
this topic, I have users,
and you have the
usual suspect fields.
I have to User ID and Region
and Gender and kind of the stuff
I want to know
about those users.
Now suppose that I have
those users in AWS.
And maybe they
arrived from something
that dumps that in S3.
I also have maybe
some page views.
I have a bunch of
stuff running on AWS.
But I really want to process it
on GCP, because GCP has things
like TensorFlow and BigQuery--
a lot of stuff that
I really enjoy using.
As a developer, you always
have your favorite tools.
And some of them
happen to be in GCP.
Getting data from cloud to cloud
is actually a hard problem.
This is something
that you think is
going to be easy until you
basically go and try to do it,
and you figure out
that, if all you know
is the stuff within your
cloud, that's not going
to help you move anywhere else.
Confluent Replicator that
is based on Kafka Connect
basically allows you
to copy some data.
So you go into Kafka
Connect, and you choose
what topics you want to copy.
So you can have a
whitelist, a blacklist,
may be everything
except the test
topics, a regular expression.
You can basically type in the
topics that you want to copy.
And then you can see a bit
down you have, where does that
come from.
In this case, it comes from AWS.
And a bit farther
down, a lot of security
configs, and it's going to be,
where is the data going to?
It's going to GCP.
Oh, more configuration
to talk through--
I can rename the topics.
So I can say that the topic used
to be called AWS.users I want
to rename it to start with GCP.
So it will kind of
make a bit more sense
and know where the
data came from, where
it went to, what is the topic.
Those hierarchical topic
names are kind of common.
Once I'm happy with
the config, I just
go ahead, start this Replicator.
And let's go and see
the topics in GCP.
So here we go.
We did the rename, so
it's GCP.AWS.users.
Now, the first thing
I want to check
is that my schema
arrived intact,
that my data is more or less
the way I expect it to be.
So I go in and say,
browse schema, once again.
And you kind of say,
yep, looks the same.
I have the region, the gender,
everything that I expected.
Now, let's go back and see
what is the data actually like.
So we go to a different topic.
Remember, Replicator
two topics--
the page views and my users.
Let's go to the page
views and use KSQL to see
what is the data in my topic.
So I do query using KSQL.
And the first thing
I have to do is
create a stream, which is
basically a materialized view
on top of the topic.
I have one already
existing, so no big deal.
And once again, you can
see it's a very simple.
I do select*, run the query.
Behind the scenes, it starts
a stream processing job,
the consumer.
And pretty soon, you'll see
a stream of events on screen.
And this is a live
stream of events.
You can see the user ID and
the page the user is viewing.
You can see the timestamp.
And as data keeps
coming into the topic,
you can see that I have more
and more events to go through.
You can see this is
a pretty busy topic.
So you can see that
we are accumulating
more and more events in there.
Now, this is kind
of a simple query.
Suppose that I want a
subset of the events.
Suppose that they want only
page views from a single gender
in the audience.
Well, the page view topic does
not have anything about gender.
But it has user ID.
And the user topic has
the gender of each user.
So I can join those
two streams of events
and then do a filter
based on the other field,
very normal thing.
This is a continuous query.
So it's a query that
basically does an ETL
job that runs all the time.
The results go into a new topic.
Now what do I do
with the results that
go in your new topic?
Well, I may want
to analyze them.
That's why I ended up in
GCP, in order to analyze it.
So what I want to do
is take those events,
dump them into, say,
BigQuery, and now
the sky is the limit, right?
You can use Google Data Studio,
and there's tons of tools.
So I go again to Kafka
Connect and create
a sink connector that uses
Google BigQuery as a connector.
So I pick the topic--
the subset of page views
that I already created.
I pick the BigQuery connector.
I give it a name--
say, Google BigQuery.
And then I start
configuring this topic.
And you can see that,
if you use BigQuery,
those configurations
should be super familiar.
Which tables do I want
the topics to go into?
What is the project?
What are the views?
All those things that
I've already used to sink.
Once I'm happy with my
configuration, I click OK,
and I'm done.
And think about it--
this was a seven-minute demo.
We got data out of AWS,
into GCP, queried it,
created a continuous
transformation,
and dumped the data into
BigQuery into further analysis.
So this is kind of--
if I may say so myself--
kind of a big deal.
It used to be
incredibly difficult,
because I know I've
been trying to do it
for a pretty long time.
So this is really
one part of the value
of having an open-source,
open-standard software is
that you are not
locked into a vendor.
You can deploy and have the
same experience in every cloud,
and you can easily move
between the clouds.
Now, if you remember two
things from this presentation,
the first is that streaming
platform gives a lot of value
to the business, and data
sharing gives a lot of value
to the business.
But it really takes an
ecosystem of tools that
exists around Apache Kafka.
You cannot do it with
just a messaging system.
You need a lot more than that.
And that, if you don't want to
go through the pain of having
to learn how to manage it
yourself, which takes a while,
you may want to run Confluent
Cloud on public cloud
of your choice--
hey, GCP is a nice one--
and make us do it for you.
Now in order to go home
and try it yourself,
Confluent Cloud
arrives in two flavors.
Enterprise means that you
have to call a salesperson
and talk to them.
This is our unlimited-scale
enterprise level.
We have SLAs.
We have support.
We have VPC peering.
You have security options.
When Boerge wants to move
into Confluent Cloud,
willing that maybe
he'll choose to do it,
this is probably the
options that he will use.
Now, if you're a team
of developers who want
to experiment with Kafka,
you don't need huge clusters,
you don't need tons of support,
you just want to try a bunch
of stuff, create a
lot of clusters--
pretty much what I
did here in the demo,
just spin up a bunch of
clusters and try stuff out--
Confluent Cloud Professional is
the tool for you and your team.
I hope you'll all run
home, and I'll basically
look at our dashboard and see
this uptick in Confluent Cloud
Professional users, because
you're all trying it.
That's it.
We'll still be around for the
rest of the event, I guess.
BOERGE SVINGEN: Yes.
GWEN SHAPIRA: So if you want to
catch us with extra questions
that you are shy to ask in
public, we'll be super happy.
Confluent has a booth
down on [INAUDIBLE] South
if you want to catch
some of our cloud experts
who are going to be around.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Thank
you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]